tutti
bentornati su nani taiz oggi nuova
challenge che non abbiamo mai fatto
prima una regione che sta andando molto
di moda del in america che si chiama
inglese cloud drive switch off challenge
praticamente niente perché l'ho detto
ancora come punte ora vi spiego è
rapidamente concussione
allora scusate che fermo rima c'è un po
pagano su carta poi ti spiegherò meglio
comunque in pratica io qua sotto o nelle
file di slime 1 slime è uno slideshow
buono messo bene bello dimesse l'altro
slime è un claim schifoso come ad
esempio quello che abbiamo fatto col
meglio
in pratica io andrò freddarli mi metterò
sotto ogni scatola in una colombo né una
quello schifoso poi mischiano bene le
scatole stati andrò a metterli senza
guardare
mi chiamo bene le scatole le tv chiamo e
poi ognuno può decidere se tenerlo o
cambiato ogni turno ognuno del cile 7
merlato cambiarle o la scatola e
qualsiasi lei ci sia dentro anche se c'è
quello schifoso bisogna aprirlo e
toccarlo in b per telethon in
grandissimi soprattutto perché ho visto
uno slide che non solo uno ho visto
molto di slam che fanno novità nei fatti
vivi
chiunque capitan pedis live sarà insomma
molto sfortunato mi raccomando lasciate
un bel laica 10.000 lines andremo a fare
la seconda parte semi che sarà questa
allen gen
mettetevi comodi popcorn patatine e
iniziamo subito da sopra
ok
[Musica]
ok abbiamo dato il nostro primo live
inizia tu non vuoi cambiare o non
ritenere ok andiamo a vederli non mi
ricordo quale sia quello cattivo tra
questi due bande ha giudicato dal ruolo
di questa sembra una zuppa di spinaci
mi sa che quello pensando se quello è
quello che avevi fatto tu che mi messo
la mostarda legno picchiando rinunciano
sì è vero perché diventato perde city
capitato che la cosa da fare che io ho
quello bello grafiche bella glitter
questo slime allora inizio io e in
mercole mani dentro in questo progetto
rosso verde bicolor sembrato poco dopo
ok ora il toccante fede dell'ictus lime
che sta sopra sembra che bello
poverino miele dentro in realtà l'odore
che emana la colla c'è la colla
trasparenza perché sente l'odore di di
mandorla che è buonissima però si sente
pure alla sera perché a sentire che
siamo un ufficio vai 20 le mani dentro
ed io l'ho capito rivedere bene come
fantasma dove schifo dai manigrasso
questi soldi fanno vedere sentire rumori
che fabbro giro protesta così almeno non
sento l'odore acquistano dietrologica
cosa sembra è uno di quelli in flight
page proprio addio
strano perché si sente l'odore della
della colla che odora di mannar la prova
siamo quindi il primo racconto che già
aveva immesso siamo stati insieme
che schifo
ma cosa sono quei pezzi non si mette a
fuoco ma forse era vincere tutto
appiccico ok ma stiamo secondo line
ok di impronte berte camera mi dici cosa
ma renzi questo allora
[Musica]
allora lui decidere se tenerlo o
cambiarlo
[Musica]
lo tengo io lo scambio si è un altro con
le palline forse questo per il nostro
male ma quando mascarino un bug le slide
stesso si è messo il volto indurito non
si capisce cosa che sufficiente questo è
quindi questo caso è quello malandato
ecomica come faranno un po troppo di
cifre per vedere martina mano dentro un
bellissimo suono dei bellissimi suoni
questo caspita che mr che riesce a fare
è diventato un po glossy dietro quarto
cioè non ci posso credere è stato zitto
fino ad ora
ora che vedremo qua in camera vuole le
nostre attenzioni e continua a usare che
vi faccio vedere il mio che po
particolare un pezzo di pelle vito che
ha tolto questo scrive che mi viene come
gli se vi ricordate quando ho fatto
questo slime dai comunque pensavo peggio
sicuramente il suo più bello anche più
suoni che sono stati commessi che cresce
invece
[Musica]
quindi ha un gusto quale vuole anche
questo per ogni istituto latino
[Musica]
mamma mia quanto aiuta i ragazzi
ed hai guardato a non guardare non
guardare
andrew guardo non guardare ma non sa
neanche di cosa c'è di vero
e tempo
di via venti alla famiglia che sapevo
che cosa a parte che non è che sentono
no no io non lo conosco l'ho visto
adesso madama sala muffa quando non lo
vogliono capire questo mio faccione
buffa o mio figlio e lo slime più chi
foto al mondo ma ci diventa ci ha messo
l'angelo amici sì 9 no vabbè funzionano
la mostra the study questo non ci posso
infilare le mani da introiti pò aglio
formaggio ammuffito giorno mio dio che
schifo l'aglio i cereali
catch up o mio dio è lo slime più
schifoso al mondo guarda e pure liquido
cioè io penso a parte che non è per
spirare penso che se stato questo trend
muoiono correttezza fiore botta e poi
vado a lavorare bari torino c'è tutto
c'è solo un genio domande non sa più che
ha ridotto così male un pittogramma
ridotto male ma non pensavo a questi
ribelli che si sono stato fortunato ma
se capitava non è molto alta
sono altresì non solo di quello tutto
dai tocca quello sguardo più bello tutto
glitter o da altre fanno vedere
bellissimo quello che so io ma sabrina
bellissimo addio a qualsiasi ombra motto
che bellissimo non mi piace
se volete la situazione definita ecco
perché finora aveva sempre una scelta vi
piace ai caduti di date che potete date
tutte guidate potete dare il voto
donna10 a ogni latte di questi rischi
fois che quelli belli sono con me non
piace tanto sono stato fortunato
reinterpretano la terra si chiama
islanda o che grazie live da guardare ma
non solo
[Musica]
chi gioca a decidere non ho mai
scambiato finora lo scambio io no mi
dispiace 12332 uno che si muove perché
su così quelli di taglia 40 invece ma
che che c'è un cavolo viola sotto non
miglioramento come è stato creato questo
flash sinceramente mi sembra che un mix
di tanti slime tutti di mestre che
questo aveva mischiato valigia in tutti
assieme per vedere come uscivano ma il
risultato non è stato ma ora si è
asciugato col bicchiere attento
fighissimo questo studio non si riesca
ad aprirlo ma perchè non potevi tokay
tutto questo di parate non capisco
dedizione dalla partenza interno
inquietante perché hanno la protezione
di teatro
basta da invitalia oggi estremamente non
è sciolto non capisco perché si muove
come se ci fosse dell'acqua dentro e
scioccante perché ha fatto tiro a giro
si è seccato perché il tappo era gatto
sembra tipo quelli splash page expert
slime ma anche l'aspetto non è proprio
dei migliori portando a noi appiccicosi
stimolo vediamo sotto
[Musica]
oddio non penso che sia c'è posso
provare a salvarlo mettermelo
dell'attivatore ma l'aspetto rimane
questa dovrebbe essere day time based
aiuto statale male e bene una volta di
arline quello a cui sono abituato il
volto con particolare si intende per la
liga levi piazze che la il castoro 19
reti che capiti a tette lo metti proprio
di prendere l'ultimo quadrini ho preso
troppi allora vado a lavarmi le mani e
poi facciamo l'ultimo a chi vuol dire
divertirti con quello
kakà è questo signore che chiude al
comando nato come buttar via ci riesce a
trovare animali della specie bacchettare
fine ha chiuso bene pratica c'era una
berlina come via treni sporchi gli
sporchi
[Risate]
[Musica]
e adesso non che io lo scarpino
no no non era lo scambio lo tieni scambi
perché non mai scambiato che ho sempre
detto ottengono tenga adesso lo stesso 3
[Applauso]
del tempo non si può sapere se lo fate
vino antico orologio ma non mi conosco
neanche così da quella che sul pellet
risulti propria circolare si sa che io
sono uno stonato particolare delle
strade fortunato
glossy come sapete non è giusto perché
decise pre sale sullo sfondo di narita
pure bello ma il proprio cibo
certo con 40 gradi e soltanto sono tutti
sciolti un problema peggio per te per
cui scambiamo con questo pratica aveva
mischiato ghislain senza colla come gli
schemi con la colla è ovviamente quello
senza colla penso che ci sia ammuffito
quello con la farina
penso che siamo titolati giustamente la
farina perché voglio facciata dell'hotel
pane windows live e non era fra i reati
sono rimasto un po in collaborazine
tagliano quello neppure la superficie
non ha un brutto dal ma ho paura quando
raggiungerò la parte a una fitta sono i
nostri collaudo non rimane così di
peggio per te
papà e zio che cosa buffa sembra un
mostro ma dentro pezzi si umani che per
far partre di sotto e proprio durissima
per i nostri voti o guarda questo tipo è
maturata la consistenza dentro io per
monte non system buffa che queste
chicchitto padri mai così dire mai ma
dentro
che schifo giuridico di ha detto che mi
mai a prenderti di riesling wars parte
in testa si sapere nei commenti qual è
secondo voi lo slide più schifoso di
tutti
invece qual è stato lo drive più che i
nomi tutti nota si siano sciolti un bel
po ma la puzza perché conoscono
se volete che riportò una legge del
genere o altri fly belli al the flag
schifosi lasciate belhaj che a 10.000
likes andremo nei primi un'altra e oltre
a minas 4 play li potete cliccare sul
quadratino che volete per vedere i
prossimi video dello speciale insieme
video divertenti mail slime nuovi video
cliccate quella che preferite una video
[Musica]
[Applauso]